it's just evolved into this like four
guy hang it is definitely a hang yeah
and I love it because it is like the
most I'm saying the crazy [ __ ]
yeah when the podcast is on or my wife's
in the car she's always like what the
[ __ ] are you listening to
me yeah what's wrong with you my wife
doesn't listen there's episodes where
I'm like hey I think you'll like this
one yeah listen to this one don't listen
to this one because you might divorce me
yeah yeah she's just like all right fine
no it's great because it's like today's
uh you know obviously climate it's just
nice to have a place where like there's
just zero [ __ ] yeah well I think Andrew
probably knew this on some level and I
maybe did but I won't even give myself
that much credit if you think about like
when somebody when there's always this
like uh there's always
too much like as an overcorrectness for
anything of course there's always a
little voice that's dissenting and like
we don't need all this so when
everybody's getting so PC and so PC I
think we were the first one of the first
at least to be like yo [ __ ] all that
let's just have fun and if the intention
is to be funny and not to hurt feelings
great Andrew I said Judge Me by my
intentions and I've always agreed with
that like that's a comedy right yeah
that's comedy we're trying to be funny
if I'm trying to hurt your feelings in a
hateful way then [ __ ] me but if we're
just trying to be funny and I'm making
it all funny then great has ever been a
a a episode or like a moment where you
were a little nervous about
whether they cancel culture people were
coming for y'all or not cancel culture
or just for just like you know because I
feel like obviously if you come from a
traditional Indian background you know
what I mean but there you guys be saying
some [ __ ] on there man uh you know what
I just in my mind I'm like my parents
don't know how to use the internet I
don't know why but I like it it's so
stupid but I'm like my mom is 67 she's
not using this she's not she's not
diving into the four a seven minute Mark
of this episode yeah it don't matter
yeah so I don't ever consider it and
I've told them from the moment I started
stand up I was like don't watch don't
watch I just say just if I'm making
money be happy for me but please don't
watch because I can't live with it
because I do think about that a lot